welcome back to memory episode three
today we're going to be looking at
unreal engine and how
they do some of the cool things in their
engine with c
plus plus code so i've been studying a
lot of these
uh coding tutorials and trying to figure
it out but also we're going to look at
the source code
and see if we can explain well what all
this u property stuff means basically
so when you code with unreal engine and
c
plus plus you have things like these
macros called
you property and you give it some stuff
and you you often put these right before
you declare
variable or function and stuff like that
and it does something very special to
the life cycle
that we're going to examine to see a
real world case
of the life cycle and hopefully this
kind of brings
the previous two tutorials together
uh into into something that's like hey
you actually really can do this
so stay tuned
one of the things we see here is
blueprint function
libraries there's a lot of things you
can do with c plus plus and unreal
one of the cool things you could do is
make static helper functions
and you see that these need certain
headers
and they basically only contain static
methods that are available to your whole
project
that's something i'm kind of used to
doing a c plus plus when making
libraries because that's a lot of times
what you end up doing so unreal does
have
some macros that enable that the thing
they do is they
expose properties in the editor so
unreal of course has a big old editor
so if you have things in your
programming that are labeled as you
property
added anywhere and they're attached to
some object or something they will be
editable from the engine interface
so there is a tie there and a flag and a
bit of code that handles
making that available to unreal so
let's see if we can find that before we
get to the code let's go ahead and
define
exactly what we're looking at and i
think it's best explained here in game
play
architecture about programming and
scripting
so when programming gameplay elements
using c plus plus code each module
can contain c plus classes as you'll see
here by this little thing
functions and properties in a class for
each module
and i'm just going to go ahead and read
some of this each class
defines a template for a new actor or
object within the class header file
class and any class functions and
properties are declared classes can also
contain structs
data structures that help with
organization and manipulation of related
properties
structures can be defined on their own
interfaces allow additional gameplay
behavior to be implemented by
different classes when programming with
unreal engine it is possible to have
standard c
plus classes functions and variables
these can be defined using standard c
plus
syntax however u class u function and u
property macros can be used to make
unreal
aware of these new classes functions and
variables
for instance a variable with a
declaration prefaced by you property
macro
can be garbage collected by the engine
and can be displayed and edited
with unreal editor there are also you
interface
you struct and you struck macros and
keywords for each macro that can be used
to specify the behavior of the class
function
property interface or struct within
unreal engine
and unreal editor in addition to the
above macros
there is u param macro that is primarily
used
when exposing c plus plus code to
blueprints to see examples of uforam
being used
see exposing gameplay elements to
blueprints documentation
and here we have the main ones listed
now i'm not entirely sure how much i
should be digging into how to program
with unreal engine but we do have to
look at some of this so
i'll just show a few things that i found
cool basically about it
so when you're templating or i don't
know if templating
is the right word when you're making
classes in unreal they can have a prefix
and if as a prefix of a
extends from a base class with spawnable
objects and if it has a
prefix of u it is a base class of all
gameplay objects these objects cannot be
or these cannot be directly
instanced in the world they must belong
to an actor they're generally objects
like components
so that is that okay so i could go
through and talk about each one of these
in the gameplay architecture but they're
rather
long-winded and specific so i'm not
going to do that
i'm really trying to give an overview
but i would highly recommend of course
reading through all this documentation
or at least what's relevant to you if
you are
in fact doing some c plus plus
programming in unreal as it does seem to
be rather
thorough so let's see if we can get to
the part where
these macros are actually put in place
because we know basically what they do
they add properties to classes and
functions and things and they make them
available in the lifetime of the unreal
editor
so basically what it does here is
something called reflection
with the unreal property system and as
defined in this
semi-old article by michael nolan
reflection is the ability
of a program to examine itself at
runtime
this is hugely useful and is a
foundational technology of the unreal
engine powering minute
many systems such as the details panels
and editors serialization garbage
collection network replication
blueprint c plus plus communication and
so on
it does say however c plus plus doesn't
natively support any form of reflection
so unreal has its own system
to harvest query and manipulate
information about c plus plus classes
structs member variables etc
the reflection system is opt-in and
that's
where these pre-processors come in these
are how you opt in to the reflection
system so if i'm
understanding this correctly when it
does its reflection it looks for these
checks out everything and sets up the
engine
appropriately for whatever you're
looking at so just looking at what's
available to us
through unreal just there the public
objects there is a u
object which looks like it is a type
called no export types
and when we take a look at that it looks
like it is a set of reflection mirrors
of c plus
plus structs defined in core and core u
object
and this is like a locked file read only
it looks like this is
some basic editor settings that are set
up within
unreal oh there's log times and
just all kinds of stuff for the editor
it looks like pixel formats
and stuff you can't change so that's
pretty interesting that they're using
this to
configure the editor itself just as you
can with your games and if we keep going
we'll see that this is uh
about 1500 lines of things including
the direct base class for all ue4
objects
and then it tells you where the full
class is
so it looks like you can only see so
much through the editor itself but if
you go to where you installed the unreal
engine
i have it on my d drive under program
files and then epic games there's ue
4.25 we will see some stuff here
so let's go into engine and you'll see
source
you can also see a lot of other cool
folders to poke around at if you get
curious
but we're going to look at source and
runtime and we're going to see if we can
find that object
so it says it's at okay runtime core u
object there it is public u object
and object.h object
dot h all right so we could actually
take a peek at this
too let's just drag it into here as you
can see it is a locked file it doesn't
want us to edit it what we're interested
in finding here is
some hints at how they do the life cycle
within the engine
so i'm going to dig through this a
little bit and see what i can figure out
and i also notice if i try to edit this
file anywhere
it yells at me and says you're trying to
edit read-only files do you want to mark
these files as a writable
which you can of course override if you
have admin rights on your computer and
make them editable
but it might bug out unreal so do some
research before messing with these files
i'm not really sure
i'm just kind of trying to peek around
at them i don't want to edit them right
now
so just fair warning okay so i'm getting
deep in the realm of a lot of different
classes and stuff that i'm not sure what
order they go in
so this would take quite a bit of
research to really dig in but i did find
this object macros class
which does seem to take whatever your
flags are
and turn them into white code that way
they're about as efficient as it can be
and you'll see that for pretty much
every flag you can use every one of
those macros
there's the class flags there's property
flags
and there are just so many files to go
through
to fully figure this out so i imagine
the guys behind unreal
are they're probably a select group of
like two or three people that are all
really good at knowing this whole thing
very few more than that
there's a lot of code behind all this to
get their editor all working
properly and using this reflection
system
and this is just one public folder it
looks like their
h files are public and let's see
they have all the cbd files some h files
apparently
so i'm not sure exactly what that reason
is unless they're exporting it and you
only ever need to
access the headers because everything
else is defined in some sort of library
i'm not entirely sure but okay so this
is just the
runtime stuff source runtime they have
all this code
each one of these probably has a good
chunk of stuff so as you can see is
definitely a ton of code
hopefully this all makes some sense and
helps bring some awareness to how
unreal does their stuff i just guess it
didn't really get to the point of stuff
but i'm sure
in somewhere deep in here they're
probably using
shared or unique pointers to the life
cycle within the engine i'm not sure if
i'll ever be able to find that code even
if i searched all day
if someone wants to point it out in the
comments that would be awesome that way
we can all take a look alright well
thanks for watching
this video here on code tech tutorials i
appreciate you guys
[Music]
[Music]
you